the House of Representatives is gearing
up to elect its new leader the Speaker
of the House Democrats lost the majority
in the midterm elections meaning
Republicans will get to name the next
speaker replacing Nancy Pelosi who House
Republicans choose to be their speaker
will be the person who really sets how
House Republicans work with the Senate
how they're going to work with the White
House and house Democrats in the next
two years but after a weaker than
expected midterms performance
Republicans don't have that large of a
majority in the house which could
complicate the process of choosing a
speaker so here's a look at how the vote
is shaping up and what's at stake for
both parties
before the midterms California
Republican Kevin McCarthy was largely
seen as the clear front-runner Kevin
mckins as the minority leader for the
four years and he's done it with a
singular focus on winning the majority
back number one thing I'm going to do as
a leader is I'm going to listen to All
voices in the conference and we're going
to do together what is best but after
Republicans failed to deliver a red wave
in the midterms McCarthy doesn't have
the backing that he was expecting the
criticism has come from a handful of
Republicans who have kind of long-held
thiefs with this party leader and one of
those Republicans with a beef is Arizona
Republican Andy Biggs he's also running
for speaker while McCarthy was chosen by
the GOP to be their speaker candidate in
an internal vote in November the results
of that vote aren't enough to win him
the gavel here's why
on January 3rd House Republicans are
expected to have a majority of 222 to
212 Democrats with one absence to be
elected a candidate must win at least
218 votes or the majority of votes from
those present and voting in the roll
call but here's where it gets tricky
members don't have to vote for their
party's nominated candidate they could
vote for anyone even if they aren't
serving in the house Democrats aren't
expected to vote for McCarthy and at
least five Republicans have voiced their
opposition to McCarthy in recent days I
think it's far too risky to pick Kevin
McCarthy I think it's risky to have
someone leading our effort going into
2024 who vastly underperformed in 2022.
so the way the math works is if Kevin
McCarthy cannot lose five votes if he
has four detractors that will get him to
218. but he's got to work to win some of
the other folks over and make sure that
the folks who haven't announced how
they're voting are going to be in his
camp
the opposition from House Republicans
varies making it difficult for McCarthy
to address every issue Andy Biggs he's
been critical of Kevin McCarthy's
leadership Matt Gates has had long time
conflicts with Kevin McCarthy Ralph
Norman he's kind of gone back and forth
on how adamant he is in the opposition
to Kevin McCarthy some Republicans have
said they would support McCarthy if he
commits to changing some conference
rules including the motion to vacate a
chair which would make it easier for him
to be ousted as Speaker McCarthy hasn't
yet agreed to back that motion you have
a broad swath of the house Republican
conference that is back in Kevin
McCarthy but because their majority is
so narrow any handful of House
Republicans can make Kevin McCarthy's
life difficult if McCarthy can't Garner
the 218 votes needed to become speaker a
few things could happen the clerk of the
house Cheryl Johnson could repeat the
vote until someone gets a majority but
that hasn't happened that often the last
time the house voted on multiple ballots
for a speaker vote was in 1923. most
Republican lawmakers will acknowledge
they think this
one if that doesn't work they could
adjourn the house essentially calling a
timeout in order to find a solution
whether that's a different candidate or
twisting the arm of detractors in the
year ahead Republicans are facing a vote
on lifting the debt ceiling and funding
the federal government to historically
tough issues for Republicans who oppose
increased spending whoever takes this
job if it's Kevin McCarthy or someone
else is going to be setting up for an
even tougher wrangling of House
Republicans in the new Congress this is
only the first vote
[Music]
foreign